قربت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه عن تعازيها
في مقتل الشابات الفلسطينيه جاكا جانا
جاكارنا وقال المتحدث باسم الوزاره
لتبرايس انما حدث للطفله الفلسطينيه امره
ماساويه يستدعي المساءله والتهدئه من جميع
الاطراح
ماساوي عندما يقتل مدني في هذه الانواع من
العمليات نعلم ان الجيش الاسرائيلي فتح
تحقيقا ونامور ان تكون هناك مسائله في هذه
القضيه لاحظنا ان رئيس الوزراء المنتهيه
ولايته لبيد قدمت اعزيه لعائله جنازه
كارني التي توفيت في سياق العنف المتساعد
في الضفه الغربيه الذي اعرضنا عن اسفينا
لحدوثه منذ فتره ارتفاعه عدد الوفيات
والاصابات بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
بمن فيهم العديد من الاطفال ووفاه
الفلسطينيه الشابه امر مقلق نؤكد على
ضروره اتخاذ جميع الاطراف خطوات لتهدئه
الوضع من الضروريه ان يتخذ الطرفان
اجراءات عاجله لمنع سقوط مزيد من الارواح